demain cela fera un an que nos deux
confrères et leurs trois accompagnateurs
sont retenus en afghanistan
cet après midi les familles d'hervé
ghesquière et de stéphane taponier ont
été reçus au quai d'orsay pour visionner
une vidéo qui daterait de la mi-novembre
les deux journalistes sont amaigris mais
ils ont bon moral
on fait le point avec sylvain le kent
les parents de stéphane taponier
arrivent tôt quai d'orsay cet après-midi
visages permet ils sont venus des
alpes-de-haute-provence pour visionner
la dernière vidéo envoyée par les
ravisseurs
la dernière preuve de vie parvenus la
semaine dernière aux autorités
françaises cinquante minutes plus tard
il ressort bouleversé non sa seconde
c'est aussi très émue mais souvent merci
d'être là au bon moment
12 ans et son copain mais non mon moral
il n'en dirai pas plus de choses que ça
qu'est ce qu'ils vous ont qu'est ce
qu'ils disent sur la cassette gens qui
sont que le gouvernement fasse le
maximum
demain cela fera un an que stéphane
taponier hervé ghesquière et leurs trois
accompagnateurs ont été enlevés sur
l'une de ces routes d'afghanistan alors
qu'ils réalisaient un reportage pour le
magazine pièces à conviction depuis un
an à plusieurs reprises les autorités
françaises ont évoqué l'imminence d'une
libération autant d'espoirs déçus pour
les familles amis laissent transparaître
aujourd'hui un certain agacement se
trouve que depuis deux bêtes depuis leur
détention on nous dit que ça sera la fin
de l'hiver puis au début du printemps
puis avant l'été et la fin de l'été
ensuite il ya eu le ramadan ce rappel
ramadan puis après ça sera donc avant
noël et finalement est ce qu'il se passe
pas grand chose vous entendez les
critiques des familles nous les
entendons et nous les comprenons et nous
les comprenons parce que la situation
cette attente et est très dur nous la
partageons demain des rassemblements de
soutien seront organisés à paris devant
l'hôtel de ville à 11 heures ainsi que
dans plusieurs villes de france pour
exiger la libération des deux
journalistes et de leurs trois
accompagnateurs du bien enfin un seul
six autres otages français détenus dans
le monde